new research suggests have breakthrough
in the treatment of some brain cancers
doctors using the polio virus to treat
aggressive brain tumors call
glioblastoma support promising results
Senator John McCain has this type of
cancer and so did Senator Ted Kennedy of
the 61 patients treated in once don't
in one study rather 21% were still alive
at the three-year mark now that's
compared with just four percent of
patients who received standard cancer
treatment sixty minutes has been
reporting on this trial at Duke
University over the past three years
four years ago Debbie puffer was told
she had at most two years to live then
she got the polio treatment in this
trial and everything changed I mean
there were days that weren't as great as
others but I I didn't even get depressed
you know I just kind of kept pushing on
pushing on pushing on I thought geez
maybe I'm cured R dr. David agus leads
the Westside Cancer Center at the
University of Southern California David
good morning it's remarkable to hear
these figures so tell everyone how this
treatment works morning Nora yeah it's
certainly very exciting you know
millions of people around the globe or
affected by viruses from HIV to
hepatitis to Ebola and the knowledge of
viruses has translated to a big advance
here in glioblastoma a catheter is
placed into the brain in a person with
Globus Noma and this is after standard
treatment of radiation and chemotherapy
and viruses infused and this polio virus
and likes to go to neurons and
particularly brain cancer cells have the
sensor the receptor it's accumulated
there and then the immune system says oh
my gosh these cells are strange and they
start attacking them so the immune
system attacks the glioblastoma and what
you're seeing here is that three years
at the best cancer centers in the
country 3 4 % of people are alive with
this aggressive form of brain cancer in
this study 21 percent it's not a hundred
percent but it's a dramatic advance in
the treatment of this disease shooting
the the polio virus into your brain
sounds very dangerous how risky is it
yeah I would not do this at home Gail
yeah it's certainly risky as any
treatment is but unfortunately at this
stage in disease
you're willing to take risk because the
patients may have weeks two months to
live with this form of brain cancer but
it causes inflammation and that
inflammation sometimes in the beginning
it gave too much virus and actually
killed too much of the cells at once and
cause seizures in the patients and so
the key is kill a little bit at a time
to hopefully get a significant benefit
for the patient David do you do it after
those other treatments chemotherapy and
radiation yeah John that's the key is
that you know standard treatment works
chemotherapy and radiation buys time
with this disease and then uniformly the
disease recurs and its ugly head comes
up again and this is for that recurrent
disease to treat it and this really is
the first major hope in treating
recurrent glioblastoma David since
you're a cancer expert I want to ask you
about this new Harvard study that just
came out on flight attendants that
showed that they have a higher
prevalence of every cancer that was
examined especially breast cancer
melanoma and non-melanoma what's going
on yeah so this is a questionnaire that
was given to flight attendants there
were 80% female and the questionnaire
showed that compared to controls these
are other people who are age match and
similar distribution that there was more
cancer was it their lifestyle they have
very strange hours they're up at night
they're up very early in the morning was
it the fact they're exposed to
carcinogens and fuel and other things on
the plane or was it the ionizing in the
UV radiation they're exposed to when
they're 30,000 feet in the air we don't
know there's an association here I
wouldn't change flight patterns yet but
these big data studies are gonna start
to come out as we see these and it's
hard to know whether it's association or
causality the trackage that the
challenge is to actually prove what's
causing things so this is an initial
data set hopefully more data will give
us answers and when they give us more
answers dr. agus will have you back
thanks so much thanks David